speaking of 4k 4k Jeff Gerstmann hello
you guys did a good old scoop yesterday
yesterday yes yes yesterday yeah i was
reading this austin walker reporting on
a bunch of stuff that came out of I mean
there was rumors Renji dc'd people yeah
there's Kaz McDonald's a hearing people
talk in line about this PlayStation 4.5
yeah and then you guys got a lot more
substantial information yeah yeah we
ended up getting a hold of the specs for
the unit and and some of the is its
developer focused documentation on the
Meo which is a code name for the right
created I want to meet who is coming up
with Sony's code names project morpheus
morpheus now neo contributed a B it's on
the way at some point orbis and beat all
the stuff they come back then linked up
in a weird way now they got this check
out our new console the Nebuchadnezzar
right yeah totally yes so it was its
developer focused information about how
the upgraded PlayStation 4 codename neo
will work and some of the timing around
win third party games are expected to
have that neo support built right in
right so the specs are what they are i'm
not going to like sit here and recite
numbers yeah if you have them we could
talk about jaguar cores right I know
yeah you guys talk about on the bombcast
a bunch yeah yes yes but you know it's
it's a it's a better CPUs a higher
higher clock speed for the CPU it is a
better GPU and it is a higher frequency
for the the ram it seems like the
processor is probably the most biggest
upgrade in that seems oh yeah that's
that's the thing you kind of hear about
being maybe a bottleneck for some of the
existing PlayStation 4 games so that
might be something that where that would
would see some benefit cool but I'm not
necessarily like mr. graphics mr.
technical um so for me like looking over
this stuff it seems interesting kind of
the positioning of it and what they are
and aren't allowing developers to do
with the games so you like there will be
no neo exclusive games right in the
documentation straight up says that yeah
yeah this will be this will be an
upgraded version of the PlayStation 4 it
will play your existing games it will
and it will also play games that are
that will run differently on
an upgraded ps4 as opposed to the
original ps4 but every disc you buy will
work in both so developers will have to
comic come up with like two versions of
the specs yeah and the neo is kind of
built for 4k at least the display
resolution will have a scalar that it
can output to 4k TVs but that doesn't
necessarily mean that games will run
yeah if Lee at 4k because that's
something that pcs have a hard time
device I mean 4k is like it's it's at
least four times as much as 10 it's like
it's an incredible amount really hard
it's the sort of thing where you have
like two or three graphics cards in a PC
like when when Microsoft first showed
that free forts a thing right running
they were like surround a 4k and you
look behind the guy giving a demo and
there's just this mountain piece clear
case like oh just straight out of a rich
man's land party uh and and yeah it's
you know it's it's a hard thing to do
right now it won't always be i mean you
know nvidia is getting ready to announce
more stuff everything's always getting
more powerful but if they're saying 4k
in the documentation that must be a
reason why they're saying for okay so is
that sony being Sony and trying to you
know well so that everything will
probably scale I mean you know all these
consoles now have a scalar in them that
will output whatever resolution you tell
it to regardless of the native
resolution so then in the documents they
kind of provide some potential options
for developers making games and working
in neo mode or as opposed to base mode
which is what they were going to the
Richards ps4 stuff loop in Revelation
call them so in in neo mode games are
expected to you know output at 4k and
and render at a resolution no lower than
1080 right so they're kind of saying
like here's some different ways to kind
of achieve handling outputting to 4k
while still detecting if there's not a
4k TV plugged in and making sure you're
doing stuff at 1080 properly and so
they're kind of providing a few
different options based on I assume
they're early work on developing games
for this thing as kind of a way forward
for third parties but you know this is
basically still the PlayStation 4 your
account will come over all of your games
and saves will come over your PSN
account like all the stuff you would
expect to come right in comes right
and controllers will work all that sort
of stuff so it's really more about this
kind of neo mode concept so as of
October games that are hitting the
streets in October developers shipping
games will be expected to be supporting
neo mode right then and there expected
that is that will be part of the
requirements to ship a PlayStation 4
game right well as of October
late-september you will be expected to
have a day one patch enabling neo mode
ok all right none of these documents
actually refer to a release date for the
device and they do in fact say that
they're okay with the idea of developers
shipping neo supporting games ahead of
the release of the upgraded console ok
so we can't necessarily pin this down
and say well obviously the consoles come
in October but it probably won't get out
before october right it could be early
next year you know we don't really know
but this is their holiday console then
this is could be yeah or it could be a
q1 console I don't know okay we won't
know until they officially start talking
about it which they still haven't done
yeah um so yeah that that's kind of the
the interesting stuff you know their
requirements include stuff like in neo
mode the game must run at at least the
same frame rate it's not better than the
the base mode version of the game
developers at will at you know
developers that have games on the market
already or games that are shipping
before late-september they will have the
option to patch neo support into their
games hmm and I can think of a few games
that that would be great for price
fallout 4 would make would maybe benefit
from that I station forwards um and and
and that sort of stuff will kind of see
how developers take to that if the
passions of being a lot of work and the
game's not super popular I don't really
see a lot of reason for developers to go
back and do that work yeah but those
games will still run on a neo the Neo
can't run in base mode so all that
software still runs and it should with
what they're saying we'll see how it
goes it should run just as it does on
your existing PlayStation 4 today
interesting what about neo features
because there's a mention of like you
know no there won't be a rocket League
special car in Rio melrose but then
Austin continued and said but what might
happen is a local
player co-op could be present and then
hey maybe neo mode can do eight player
co-op right there co-op offline also
that's the that's the the specifics
there you can't as a developer you
wouldn't be able to say hey if you have
a neo you'll have a higher player count
online this is 32 players on neo 16 on
ps4 online you can't segregate the user
base at all along those lines you can't
have neo exclusive features so but you
can't have enhanced versions of those
features that may run in neo boats
that's why the the the local multiplayer
thing happens the mode exists on the
base ps4 but is a four player mode right
but on neo maybe it's an eighth player
mode it's not a wording yeah is that not
a feature yeah well I guess yes it is
but they're saying like the mode must
exist in some form you can't be like
perfect dark without the expansion pack
where it's like you know you can't play
any of this stuff without this thing
it's more like you can play everything
with a base ps4 but in some cases you
may be able to say like oh well we've
raised the player count in this offline
mode because they can't segregate the
online mode so they can't do it there
and that was more provided as an example
or something that a developer could do
as opposed to like I don't know that
this will actually come to pass but you
know like so you couldn't do VR only on
the Neo ok we'd have to support it in
both places you can't do exclusive modes
but you could enhance your existing
modes as long as it doesn't segregate
the user basis this isn't going to
impact the breakout box thing we saw
with the PlayStation fiora we don't know
about that either so there there really
isn't any mention of VR in the stuff
that we've seen so I I would think that
they would build that breakout box into
the console at this point but maybe
that's a cost thing that they just don't
want to do and and all that sort of
stuff yeah it remains to be seen but
that breakout box there's no real power
in that thing for games it's ness it's
just kind of necessary for the VR stuff
to work so one way or the other it kind
of doesn't matter it would just be more
of a convenience thing the same way that
if you tried to hook a connect up to a
launch 360 right you had to use external
power whereas the later 360s just had
the connector port right on it yeah so
it seems like it'd be sort of like that
difference
it's I mean it sounds from what you were
talking about that they're taking all
the right boxes that they're like doing
right by the current consumers but also
upgrading this other one yeah but is
there an argument to be said that if
they took the shot goes off a little bit
when it comes to the older people the
water the owner playstation 4 and i'm a
playstation 4 owner myself who's placing
forward literally broke over the weekend
or last week who so this was like I mean
now you're in a tough spot right what do
you do and like if they were to care
less about current owners then they
could really yeah do something with this
does it feel like it's a little bit tame
I it's it feels this feels like these
are the these are the mandates today and
these are the mandates for launch right
and I think what happens two years from
now what happens a year from now will
depend on what the makeup of consoles in
the marketplace is hmm you know if if a
bunch of these Neos sell to the point
where that's the dominant version of the
console then maybe in a year maybe in
two years they go like all right we're
gonna we're going to relax some of these
restrictions yeah yeah you can maybe
push further into neo exclusive
territory I mean they did that with uh
was the xbox with the arcade version
were originally the hard drive on that
Union yeah you know it all it takes with
with Microsoft with stuff like that all
it took was a first party game getting
waved a lot of common things so every
time a halo would come out and do
something that other third-party games
were not allowed to do every third party
would go like well you did it for them
right so we're doing it now and there we
go okay so I you know we'll see how that
stuff goes but I think it makes sense
for out of the gate to not alienate
existing consumers and but I do agree
that it seems like if they didn't have
that restriction maybe you could lean
into the power a little bit more yeah a
little bit more out of it but at the
same time these numbers are higher but I
don't know that they're like not the
world crushingly hi you know you're not
gonna like take your like built pc and
throw it out a window now I got a neo
but yeah I don't know it's a weird spot
and I think that all of video games is
in a really weird tariff yeah between
this happening with everything
Microsoft's tried to do pushing onto the
pc in weird ways that aren't always
great yeah and what VR is starting to do
two things or once people I can actually
get a headset with that what that may do
to just video games in general like
we're entering strange uncharted
territory yeah nobody seems like they're
uneven feet at the moment yeah even you
know you look at Sony like you would
expect them to be like hey there the
market leader like they're they're kind
of able to determine a certain cadence
they can kind of sit back a little bit
there you know they're doing the thing
that like all console manufacturers do
just in a different way they're getting
to this point where hey we found ways to
make the existing console it in a more
inexpensive way but instead of like
turning that into pure profit for them
by just you know retooling their
internals yeah they're going like well
as part of that process we can actually
make it more powerful so why don't we do
that too that's a massive twist the
knife in Microsoft's back there all
right like what what does it what does
somebody coming up this Christmas
somebody wants to buy a console name for
whatever isn't helping pick one up yeah
this late in the game but this deep in
like the xbox one becomes a much more
difficult proposition I this thing I
think so too but we don't know what
Microsoft is up to you right you know
like Phil Spencer back there spring
showcase not that long ago was kind of
alluding to the idea of an upgradeable
console and this was also in context of
like hey quanta breaks coming to PC and
i fully expect that from here on out
every first party xbox game will appear
on the pc i got a message give me a free
version of it cuz i right you know
they'll do like a cross-buy no
pre-orders that's the water yeah break
yeah so they're they're trying to kind
of pull whatever levers they can to get
more excitement around their games and
get get a bigger audience you know
putting that stuff on the pc maybe
mitigate some of the lot of the them
being a bit behind the the ps4 yeah or
it can but but we don't know what
they're doing with the xbox platform
other than probably turning it more and
more into a brand obviously there's an
Xbox app on Windows 10 right there they
have multiple games you think of as Xbox
games in the windows 10 store now it
seems like they'll continue to lean into
that so why won't they then also have an
upgraded console at some point to the
division a balut it to some of that
stuff but then Spencer kind of backed
away from it a little bit and said you
know I think the quote was something
along the lines of like I'm not going to
ship someone a screwdriver in a video
card right you know which obviously no
but you
might sell them a more powerful Xbox
console at some point down the line
which all of this at some point adds up
to why wouldn't you just buy a PC yeah
that's exactly how I didn't they know
that I be like they're more they're
certainly more expensive to build if you
don't have one today but if you're not
the reasons not to the reasons to have a
console and not to have a PC which
existed 10 years ago don't exist anymore
yeah ever all the big console games are
coming MPC yeah I'm so much already
stuff is everywhere positive life stuff
is so much better on pc and their bras
before yeah there's less like [ __ ]
when it comes to hardware never was
before I mean this level yet but like
it's you know saying what the way steam
is being run you know those games go on
sale a lot so it's more expensive up
front but I bet if you're smart about it
it kind of balances out in the end it's
not for everyone i mean some people just
sit down put a disc in a thing and play
and PCs are still not that you know go
get a steam box and tell me if that it's
that not even that it's not a good
feeling like pc i have one at home and i
plan on it upgrading that soon but you
know you throw in fallout 4 i got tone
it down all the way and it's like I
would this could be better and I was
just playing like I gave me yesterday on
ps4 and now it's like what I imagine
down the road is man I wonder how cool
or how much better this would rise if I
had the Neo that's a very fresh rating
thing cuz that's what you buy a console
and you last you for five years now
you're like cool everyone's got the same
especially you imagine someone who
bought a ps4 for the first time this
week yeah you know like my brother at
convinced him last week to get a ps3
yeah yeah yeah that's in and you know
hey if you think about when the new
Nintendo 3ds came out you know right
somebody's like gamestop we're lining up
to give you a decent chunk of money for
your existing 3ds as part of an upgrade
transaction you would have to imagine
they would be doing something like that
and there's even a potential you know
case to be made for Sony to try to do
some kind of thing for their existing
right consumer base but I don't know
about that I mean the worst thing I can
think of right now is the developers
come out with like neo versions of their
games which are like you know fallout 4
neo mo version and it works on the old
one too yeah we've optimized it so it'll
work even better on that and then trying
to sell it and still catching it yeah
that's yeah that I if I were Sony that
would be the first thing I would say
you absolutely cannot do this will we
will not allow you to do this you have
to patch your existing game if you're
going to sell a game of the year edition
no though because they can't afford to
that that that would anger people that
would that would be probably a bit over
the line yeah with something that
already seems a little shaky but yeah
I'm curious to see what they say about
it when they do start talking about all
this stuff and and how they attempt to
position it because I think it is it's
an awkward move where yeah you've got
the at the high end is it is it truly
high enough if they have to be hamstrung
by the the you know the the previous
console and if you just bought the
previous console are you going to
suddenly start getting 20 frames a
second on all your games because
everyone optimizing for neo first and
foremost it's a it's a weird road to
walk down I kind of understand why they
might have chosen to do this because
it's not like the consoles were all that
powerful to begin with right they might
be getting tapped out might not have
been able to make it five years yeah but
yeah it's it's like I said it's a real
weird time III is going to be exciting
yeah guess that stuff and we got
Nintendo yeah no NX is going to come out
there and be like here's our left-field
thing that it doesn't even factor into
whatever these idiots we're our own
idiot you know they like that that's
it's really exciting it's great as long
as that Mario maker rumor turns out to
be true as long as there's a new mario
maker or port of moria annual I you guys
franchise like they always meant to this
one's got three new mushrooms pretty
great yeah less than two months until
you three exciting times who knows how
many new consoles would be staring down
the barrel of in just over two months
time Jeff Chris went thank you so much
for coming on and people want to hear
more about your breaking story on the oh
they can go to giant bombcast as well
yeah giantbomb.com the podcast is up
right now you could be listening to it
right now he could be but don't listen
for at the end of this yeah it's almost
over raavan Larry thank you so much for
coming on thank you I really appreciate
it we'll get you back out there